oh he did
these are some people of the internet
wearing a metaquest ii headset and
playing richie's plank experience
a game where you jump off a virtual
plank sometimes using a real plank to
make it seem more real this is me
playing the same game
but unlike those others
i used to trip
so i could avoid a similar fate do a
quick pass-through check
all right
[Music]
okay so you bought one of these the
oculus quest ii the quest two wait the
oculus the meta quest ii
that's it the meta quest too then you
realize this thing is really fun but
also pretty flawed and hard to figure
out sometimes mom is it you
luckily there are some hidden settings
and things you can buy that can help
with some of those issues here are eight
tips for making the quest work better
for you
strap in everyone
number one reset your direction
sometimes you don't want to keep
spinning around like this to find the
main menu or center spot in a gamer app
so reset your view look straight ahead
in the direction you want your main menu
or center of your app to appear
then press and hold the oculus button on
the right controller you'll see the
oculus logo appear once the ring reaches
all the way around the virtual world
will snap to your new center
number two double tap to pass through
i want you to remember this
furniture is the enemy of vr
that's why you should enable passthrough
a feature that gives you a camera view
albeit in black and white of your real
surroundings without taking your headset
off go to quick settings then settings
and select guardian toggle on double tap
for pass-through shortcut
now tap your finger twice on either the
left or right side of the headset and
you'll instantly see the real world
number three take screenshots
sure in whatever app you're in you can
back out to this menu here and click
take photo but that's annoying instead
on your controller just hold down the
oculus button and then hit the trigger
you'll easily be able to snap
screenshots
sadly there's no button combo for video
screen recordings like these which
brings us to
number four enable voice commands
go to settings
then system
then voice commands
enable in-app voice commands and then
the controller shortcut
now you can double press on the oculus
button and the mic will start listening
for a command
what time is it it's 10 44 at night
what's the weather right now in jersey
city it's clear in 32. you can also go
to settings
experimental features
and enable hey facebook
then you can just use the wake phrase to
give your command
hey facebook launch beat saver
number five turn on phone notifications
this
is not fun so instead get your phone
notifications sent to your headset pair
your headset to the oculus app on your
phone in the app go to menu and then
devices
then phone notifications
and then toggle it on
you can customize what phone
notifications now get delivered to your
headset
number six
strap a battery to your head an hour or
two of playing a game or wandering
around in some virtual space
and you'll see the battery get into the
red
getting battery low but not if you wear
one of these yes that's a battery pack
strapped to the back of my head this is
the kiwi power bank fixing strap for 35
dollars you get a short power cable and
this strap which has space for a battery
pack you have to have byob bring your
own battery
or you can charge your phone this way
it's very cool
if you want to go higher end and i kind
of suggest you do get meta's own 109
elite strap
battery inside here
number seven make your controllers
rechargeable
sadly the quest 2 controllers require
double-a batteries
you could of course buy rechargeable aaa
batteries or you could go for anker's 99
fancy charging station which has its own
rechargeable batteries and these special
covers so you can just dock them to
charge
number eight use your hands
you know what they say your hands are
your best controllers
[Music]
actually nobody says that but really
using your hands can be very handy when
you want to do something quickly and you
don't want to fumble for the controller
go to settings
then hands and controllers
toggle on hand tracking
there are a few gestures to master to
select something pinch
to scroll move your pinch in the
direction you want to go
i can look at my hands
here to get to some quick settings
like
it can be a bit janky but when it works
it's pretty cool
and don't worry you can easily switch
between hand and controllers the system
just picks up the right input all right
go live the dream and strap a bunch of
electronics and a big battery to your
head
i'm sure that is very good for all of us
i love my family
i love everybody
thank you for watching this video